okay we're gonna go through five
inequalities we're gonna start out with
some simple ones and get a little bit
more challenging as we go through these
see if you can pause the video and do
these on your own the first one what you
want to do when you're solving these
inequalities is you want to get the
variable by itself on one side of the
inequality and ideally you want to get
it on the left side so let's start with
this first one what I'm going to do is
I'm going to add 4 to both sides of the
inequality to keep it balanced right so
that's going to give us 20 and if 4
negative 4 cancel out and now what's the
opposite of multiplying by 5 we want to
divide both sides by 5 and that comes
out to X is less than 4 now one thing
you want to be careful of when you're
working with inequalities is that if you
multiply or divide both sides by a
negative number this inequality sign
will change directions okay or flip but
in this case we divided by positive 5 so
it doesn't change direction now when you
look at this on the number line here's 4
over here here's 5 here's 3 see how X is
less than 4 that means that it can be
any value to the left of 4 on the number
line so as these values get smaller and
smaller so it doesn't equal 4 it's just
going to be less than 4 so we're going
to draw this as an open circle okay so
not including 4 and then all the values
to the left one way that students
sometimes think about this is that you
can think of this when the variables on
the left like this it kind of looks like
an arrow see how it's pointing to the
left so all the values less than 4 to
the left of 4 ok let's try number 2 a
little bit more challenging so this one
same idea we want to get this variable
by itself on one side of the inequality
so we can think about working from the
outside in towards that variable so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to subtract
7 so I'm gonna do the opposite I'm going
to add 7 ok so now we're down to
negative 2 X is greater than or equal to
10 because the 7 and negative 7 cancel
the opposite of multiplying by negative
2 is 2 divide both sides by negative 2
so those cancel and now we're just left
with negative 5 but look what just
happened I divided both sides by a
negative number this inequality sign is
going to change directions so it's going
to feed facing the other way instead of
greater than or equal to it now becomes
less than or equal to one way to
remember this too sometimes students
feel a bit confused with the
greater-than in less then see how this
kind of looks like an L tilted so you
can think it like L for less than and
now we're just going to go to the number
line so here's negative five here this
is negative six and this is negative
four it's less than or equal to so now
this time it equals negative five okay
as well as all the values that are to
the left then or less than negative five
okay number three see if we can do this
one this was a little bit more
challenging because we have the variable
on the right side okay so let's go see
how we're going to approach that one
let's start by distributing the negative
one half so that's negative one half X
plus 7 over 2 because negative times a
negative is a positive and we've got
four on the left here still now what I'm
going to do here because I have these
fractions is I'm going to multiply
everything by two to clear the
denominators to get rid of those
fractions so if I multiply everything by
two that gives us eat is greater than
negative one X plus seven and then let's
continue to sign over up here I'm going
to rewrite it so we have eight is
greater than negative X plus seven and
then instead of adding seven I'm gonna
do the ops I'm going to subtract seven
from both sides so that's one is greater
than negative x I'm gonna get the X by
itself by dividing both sides by
negative one so now we have X and
negative one but look what just happened
I multiplied it or divided both sides by
a negative number this inequality
changes direction right but we also have
the variable on the right we want to
really get the variable on the left so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
pick up this whole in equality I'm going
to flip it over and so this is going to
be ax it's negative one see how this is
opening towards the X okay like that
it's still going to be opening towards
the X okay so I just took the whole
thing I flipped it over X is greater
than negative one or if you read this
from right to left this is like negative
1 is less than X now we can go ahead and
graph it so here's negative one here's
negative two here zero we want all the
values that are greater than but not
including negative one so greater than
we're going to the rights or all the
values that are greater okay number four
a little bit more challenging this one
we've got a variables on both sides of
the inequality I'd start by distributing
the two so that gives us 2x
- six distribute the three that's three
X plus three and now we want to get the
variables on one side numbers on the
other just like solving an equation so
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to subtract 3x from both sides so that
gives us negative 1x and then instead of
subtracting 6 I'm going to add 6 to both
sides so that comes out to 9 but we have
a negative ax which is like a negative
1x so we're going to divide both sides
by negative 1 and remember when you
multiply or divide by a negative number
that inequality sign changes directions
so we have X is less than or equal to
negative 9 and we have negative 9
negative 10 over here and negative 8
over here and X is less than or equal to
so it includes negative 9 as well as all
the values less than or to the left of
negative 9 okay number 5 last problem
see if we can do this one here we're
going to distribute the 1/4 and one
thing when you're working with fractions
it makes it a little bit easier is to
put the whole numbers over 1 because
anything divided by 1 is itself and what
you can do is you can multiply the
numerators together the denominators
together so that gives us 4 over 4 which
is 1 and then here we have 1 times 8 is
8 4 times 1 is 4 8 divided by 4 is 2 and
that's an easier way to work with
fractions and whole numbers and then now
let's just combine like terms 2 minus 1
is 1 now let's subtract X from both
sides of the inequality so those cancel
and we get 1 is less than negative 1 now
what happened to our variable it
cancelled out on both sides right and
look what we're left with is 1 less than
negative 1
no so that means that there's no
solution to this problem and if you were
graphing this on the number line you
would just leave that number line blank
okay because there's nothing that makes
this true now if it was the other way
where one was greater than negative 1
that's always true and it would be all
real numbers and you could then shade or
graph you know the entire number line
because it's infinitely many solutions
so these are special cases when the
variable cancels out if you want to see
more pre-algebra topics check out my
pre-algebra review where I go through
inequalities those walls a lot of other
PL jobra concepts in that video right
there I'll see over in that video